Hey guys,
I've got big news!
My book is finally ready for pre-order.
And this is a game changer for men!
Are you ready to hear more about my book?
Here it is.
Bold Pursuit.
It's a 90-day
devotional for men seeking the heart of God.
Here's the front cover for you on the screen.
and also the cover on the back.
Now, I just wanted to mention that I have a
few gifts for you - specifically for those of
you who are going to pre-order the book.
And one of them is an exclusive video
where I share something deep
about my relationship with God.
Something that changed my life
and that can change yours as well.
I was a Christian but I only came
to complete surrender when my dad,
my father, was about to die.
He was abiding in Christ.
He fully surrendered because
he loved Jesus Christ.
You see, you need to follow God in
everything you do to fully surrender to Him.
This book is close to my heart and I wrote it
for men who are really seeking the heart of God,
who want to grow in Him who want to abide in Him.
Have you fully surrendered to Christ?
Or is there one or two things
that you're still holding back?
Are you a do-er of the Word,
and not just a hear-er?
But as I said, that video is only for
those who will pre-order the book,
and, to tell you more about the book, what it is
all about, there's no better way than to read the
introduction to you.
So here we go.
David asked God to create in me a clean heart,
God, and renew a steadfast spirit within me.
[Psalm 51:10]
One of the most famous men in the Bible who had
an unbelievable relationship with God was David.
He was a man after God's own heart.
How many men who call themselves
Christians can say that today?
How many men ask God the same
request that David asked?
How many men are really serious
about their relationship with God?
How many men know God intimately?
I believe that all of us men should
have this deep burning desire to have a deep
relationship with God the way David did.
David walked closely with God.
And we still learn from his
life today, thousands of years later.
He had an unstoppable desire to know the
God of all creation intimately.
Not just know about Him.
This 90-day devotional was created
to help us to deeply know God.
Each devotional is a guide to grow closer to God
and learn what it means to truly abide in Christ.
I believe thousands of Christian men
today are lukewarm and they do not
realize that God will spit them out of His mouth.
There's a big problem in the church today.
A problem of lukewarm men who care more about
living for the things of this world than
about living for the God of this world.
The gospel messages we hear in many churches
across the globe are often sensational,
superficial, and materialistic.
We hear a watered-down gospel aimed
at tickling ears instead of transforming
lives and saving souls for Christ.
I wrote this book to cut through all the noise
and bring back the sound doctrine of scripture.
I want to do so in truth and love, pointing
men across the world to pick up their cross
and follow Jesus.
To respect Him.
To understand His holiness.
To seek Him and His
righteousness first, in everything they do.
Bold Pursuit calls us to radical discipleship
which can only come from wholehearted
devotion to Jesus Christ.
I will turn to the Bible and teach spiritual
truths that will help us understand what
it means to truly abide in Christ and to
fully surrender to His will for our lives.
This is what we need in the church today.
You cannot serve Christ with only your heart
or only your mind.
You need both.
In other words, you need to follow Christ
with the right doctrine and devotion.
You also need to know what it means to follow
Christ in the spirit and not in the flesh.
God has called me to share the
good news to the ends of the world.
To all people and all nations.
To teach the Word in season and out of season.
And to show people what it
means to be a reborn Christian.
My heart for this book is
that men around the world
will come to understand that the God of the past
is the same God of the present and the future.
We can have a relationship
with him like David had.
We can read and study His unchanging truth
in the Bible, in the same way Godly men did.
Men like John Wesley.
Charles Spurgeon.
Jonathan Edwards.
D.L Moody.
Billy Graham.
Andrew Murray.
And my father, Etienne
Maritz, here in South Africa.
Bold Pursuit will change us to look in
the mirror, to examine whether we are in
the faith and whether we follow Christ
with our whole heart, mind, and soul.
This book will require a new and fresh commitment
to God and a burning desire to
please Him in all that we do.
Most of us do not realize that God is more eager
to love us and answer our prayers than we are to
love Him and pray to Him.
God is always waiting.
The God of the universe is
always there waiting for us.
God is more eager to reveal himself
to us than we are to seek Him.
Wow.
It is time we turn back to God fully.
It's time we fall on our knees.
It's time we return to the Bible.
This devotional will guide you to do just that.
Before you start with the first daily devotional,
pray that God will bless you and reveal Himself to
you as you continue to work through the 90 days.
Read and work through each entry with your
Bible every day, making it a daily routine.
You see, this is especially good
for ministries, if you're a pastor,
preacher, and you have a ministry.
If you want a Bible study that men
can work together on, this is it.
There will be a few questions at
the end of every devotional and I want you
to answer them honestly and keep a notebook
close by to write down important notes
that you feel God wants you to focus on.
Finally, be humble and open so that God
can change you according to His will.
He is the potter and you are the clay.
There you go.
All the details are on the website
created for Bold Pursuit specifically.
All the details are in the
video description down below.
If you want to check it out.
If you're a man, pre-order it today.
If you're a woman, do the same thing because this
is a perfect gift for the men in your life and
there are a lot of men who need strong guidance
especially in the world that we live in today.
To become strong men, standing firm in their
faith and who follow the example set by Jesus.
In boldness, truth, love, and in the Spirit.
And, you can also read the book yourself.
I want you to know that all
the money that we receive
from the book goes directly to our ministry.
It will help put bread on the table for my team
who are working so hard behind the scenes and
it will enable us to keep on sharing the gospel,
to the ends of the world, so not only will the
book help you to grow spiritually closer to God,
but also you'll be helping us in doing what
God wants us to do: sharing the gospel to the
ends of the world.
So thank you.
Thank you for your support.
And always remember that God loves you.
And I love you too.
Bye.